the coronavirus has sidelined another  las vegas raiders starter linebacker  corey littleton  placed on the nfl's covid reserve list  he's likely going to miss  sunday's game against the denver broncos  which is a key game in the afc west  you can watch the game right here on  channel eight one o'clock on  sunday afternoon the raiders are four  point favorites  eight news now is of course your home as  the raiders nation takes on the broncos  at allegiant stadium  now because of the masters tournament  that's airing on sunday morning  our raiders pregame show will be live at  4  30 tomorrow saturday saturday  uh join our eight news now sports team  along with nfl alum brandon marshall for  a breakdown of this week's matchup with  the broncos